you caused a controversy on your last
tour you were in Utah and you sent out a
tweet that I guess ruffled some feathers
did it ruffled some Mormon feathers
should we show the tweet first then you
explain what's the best order to do this
in well just know you know everybody
knows Salt Lake City is a it's like a
depository of Mormons and and I and I
and I love to it shows I always have
great sets in Salt Lake City but so
specific to Salt Lake City we tweeted
something that was very offensive to
them yeah yeah we have it here this is
the tweet you sent out look that's
basically some long johns and then in
any other culture and so I so here's the
thing Coenen you can and Andy and all of
you and you at home but not Patti there
are two words in the English language
that by themselves are not funny or
interesting but when you put them
together they're the funniest thing ever
and that is sacred and the other word is
underwear so I made fun of their the
sacred underwear
it's a tenant one of the tenants of the
of the Mormon belief is that there there
was sacred underwear yeah and and it's
it's it's the only sane one
and they got very upset that that it was
it was s cousin new this discussion
should smooth things over
[Applause]